Vính vụ để sớt hà nội được cưỡng chế phá giữa gại lạo Trung cơ cố, khi trên 7.000 chú sử hút đồng ý,
sọng nhiều đại biểu có khội cho rằng tỷ lệ này vẫn còn cao và tình tiếp tục được xem xét,
sáng 1 áng 32, tại phiên họ có khội một trường tại chính quyến và tắng thật quyền thu tấn,
chình dự thảo việ cứa thí điểm một số cơ chế đặc thu, nhằm thu đề các giữa an lớn tại tủ đồ,
theo chính phụ, quá trình cải tạo Trung cơ cố thử dân qua gặp nhiều gương mắt, giò yêu cầu đồng thuận cao, khiến tính độ chấp,
anh hưởng đời sống và ăn toàn của người dân, vì vậy, các quán sọng thảo nề sớt hà nội,
có thể quyết định cứm chế phá giữa khi hơn 7.000 chú sử hút đồng ý,
Từng ứng bệ mấy mấy lắm phần trăm diện tích đất thủ của Kài Tạo.
Tỳ lại này thấp hơn mất đã nế phần trăm theo luật nhà ở 20, 22,
sau nhiều đại biểu cho rằng vẫn khó khả thì.
Một số ý kiến để sất giảm xuống 5 phần trăm để nhanh kại tạo chung cử xuống cấp.
Đồng thời cho các nơi chỉ tiêu quý hoài chào phạm việc hợp liến.
Máo cáo thầm chào của 8 kiên tế và tài chính điều gió,
gờ chiếc cứng trễ cũng nhiều thầm quyền quyết định các dự án lớn,
cần đánh giả ký để tránh phát sinh khíu kiện,
và bảo đam ồn định sả hội.
Dự thảo cũng để sớt phân tất mạnh cho hành hội.
Chào phê dùa chủ trường đầu tư các dự án lớn, quan trọng,
và cho phát thực hiện đồng thời một số thủ tục giảm giúp nhắn tiến nộ.
Pố hội dự kiến biểu quết thông qua dự thảo và ngày 1.8.